the Joe Rogan experience I don't think
that like I remember and I'm gonna get
blowback on this look I don't think that
W uh what had malicious intent I think
he was well intended you know he failed
at things but I think he was well
intended I think that's probably a
logical perspective and I think Dick
Cheney's probably Satan you think so I
think Dick Cheney was running me
straight from hell that's why I had that
bunker deep deep down under but I think
that bunker existed he was right wasn't
like he was like it's not like he was
like yeah I need a bunker he had a
straight shot straight to hell that's
what it was it was it was down there
that's how it was he did that's why it
was so warm that's what he remember when
he was in the bunker after 9/11 there
was a Dick Cheney's in the bunker
how come George Bush is playing golf w's
out there well because he wore head he
was in DC and there was a separation of
of powers I don't know and then we all
saw they Adam McKay movie you look how
much is that true imagine the power to
because Dick Cheney look I I you know I
also doubt everything I always quote you
know like everything I hear about I'm
kind of like cut it in half which makes
me kind of still think trumpet yes
absolutely crazy but but like you know
Dick Cheney is there like is he is and I
don't think he cares but like there's no
like the the narrative has been set for
him yeah there's no kind of like you're
not gonna believe this but Dick Cheney
is like one of the funniest storytellers
like you that's there's nothing the
narrative of Dick Cheney right like
George Wu's painting and he does a lot
of painting it's good because painting
is kind of lovely it's like it's cute
sweet staff it's like it shows you where
his mind is that this is where he
chooses to spend it but Katrina he
didn't go there right away well he hates
people according to Kanye West right but
Dick Cheney is a completely different
animal like he shot his friend in the
face and his friend apologized yeah but
he didn't do it he obviously didn't do
it on purpose I was probably drunk and
then he disappeared for 24 hours do you
know that they didn't immediately turn
himself in anyway yeah yeah he was most
likely drinking they were doing what's
called a canned hunt where they open up
these gates and they let these birds fly
out and they just start blasting them
and he shot his friend but it was it
could have been a mistake
it was a mistake but I'm known as the
dick chaney apologist nice so explain
this Halliburton so he was a CEO of
Halliburton
yeah thieves Halliburton and he he
becomes a vice president and then he
gives Halliburton these no-bid contracts
to rebuild Iraq after they blew it up
so explain that as a as a biologist um
you know I would say one no-bid
contracts happen often that's what I've
heard
how can you chew another one of those my
heart is pounded on my chest because I'm
a real man I'm more manly than you